[Music]
you know we love the movie sliding doors
and that's a 90s movie
yeah it's like the wind it's just she's
but it is such an interesting thing it's
about the idea of what if a little teeny
thing happened you're like that could
completely change the course of your
life
I'm Abby I'm Ilana we originally wrote a
version of this episode in season one
because we didn't know that we were
definitely gonna get it a second season
no less four so we were like we want to
make it feel like a series finale Amy
Poehler who is an EP on the show felt
very strongly that it was too super
pissed because when you watch a show you
you have to be invested in the
characters to care about how they met
and so but she was right it was silly to
be good to push it that wig is
unbelievable it felt like a wig to me
but it would look if I didn't hurry I
had to walk around all day like you got
bangs again I know Oh bang the clothes
were discussed
we wanted to capture like how you don't
know how to dress your body in your
early 20s or whatever I was always like
belting stuff like alabang and your
flats were horrible
it's just exactly how I dressed at that
I was like she's so oh my god - nothing
even though I'm her ook at them I think
they had him like last year so I wasn't
really wearing them it was something
[Applause]
at one point when we were writing it we
were like what are we even saying you
know in sliding doors it's like if you
see the truth it's better but we die I
forget that we were like we're friends
either way a new friend the version
where we're apart it is an upsetting day
for both of us it's like what are their
lives like without each other yeah
they're like yeah yeah hey what we were
trying to say is that inevitably these
two would have found each other and
become friends some people you are just
destined to meet and fall in love with
[Music]